what's up everybody gather here we are  on the set for my new single on I hope  we're about super state decided with my  suit back here  [Music]  [Applause]  I hope is about a story of a guy that I  was with  it was great but ended up cheating on me  with another girl but how girls are we  naturally aren't nice about it so we're  normally we really feel mean about it so  then army  [Music]  everybody we're still different - they  become an outcall I hope to effect this  video and creating such an awesome story  I'm so excited to share insights more  about to film the last scene if you wear  [Music]  thank you so much is the rap I have a  robe on because I'm freezing but I hope  y'all like the video  [Music]  [Applause]